Kate Middleton and Princess Charlotte
honor Queen Elizabeth at her funeral
with some sentimental jewelry
[Music]
Kate's necklace a stunning Pearl choker
belonged to her late grandmother-in-law
and those drop earrings a gift to the
queen for her wedding in 1947. as for
Charlotte that Diamond Horseshoe Broach
a direct nod to the Queen's Love of All
Things equestrian
we are likely never going to know the
the details of the Queen's wall because
it will remain confidential but I'm sure
that something has been left whether
that is financial sentimental piece of
jewelry from the queen to each of her
children her grandchildren and her
great-grandchildren
[Music]
in Markle who wore Diamond and Pearl
drops she got from the late Monarch one
of the Queen's great regrets was that
she didn't get to see more of Archie and
nilibert but I'm sure pieces of jewelry
special mementos will absolutely have
been reserved for those great
grandchildren too
foreign
consort went for a different piece from
the family archive she chose the Hess
Diamond Jubilee brooch which belonged to
Queen Victoria Queen Elizabeth's
great-great-grandmother